lo que en este vídeo haremos es una
explicación poco matemática digamos que
lo menos matemática que podamos respecto
a por qué los precios de los bonos se
mueven en dirección opuesta a las tasas
de interés es vamos a escribir eso vamos
a escribir que los precios
de los bonos
y cómo se está moviendo esto respecto a
las tasas de interés
y hay en el mercado
interés para empezar ocuparemos un bono
simple que nos pagan cupones los cupones
son estos pagos que se hacen
parcialmente desde el momento de emisión
hasta el momento de madurez del bono y
vamos a usar entonces estos para hablar
un poco sobre cuánto estaríamos
dispuestos a pagar por este bono en el
caso de los movimientos de las tasas de
interés que les comentaba digamos que si
una tasa de interés sube el precio va a
bajar
de igual manera al revés si la tasa de
interés baja buenos los precios tenderán
a subir los precios de estos bonos vamos
a dibujar entonces nuestro bono tenemos
aquí un bono que va a ser este papel
digamos que es un bono o un préstamo que
estamos haciendo le puede ser
gubernamental o puede ser a una empresa
en este caso vamos a ponerle compañía
compañía a digamos entonces que este
bono tiene un tiempo de madurez de dos
años vamos a poner aquí compañía a con
dos años
de madurez es decir el tiempo en el que
se nos va a recuperar el monto de este
bono y son dos años con cupones o pagos
parciales semestrales vamos a ponerle
cupones
de pago al 10%
semestral
mestral
hoy creo que me sale un poco este bono
lo vamos a adquirir por
mil dólares en dos años recuperaremos
los mil dólares y tendremos una tasa
anual del 10 por ciento que nos darán
pagos semestrales durante estos dos años
entonces tenemos ya aquí nuestro
certificado de bono y haremos entonces
un diagrama de pagos les parece bien
digamos que el día de hoy lo voy a hacer
en este color
hoy estamos comprando nuestro bono ok y
tendremos este tiempo de madurez de dos
años
de dos años serán igual a 24 meses 24
meses al futuro recuerda que estamos
viendo el futuro este es el día de hoy
y en 24 meses madurar a nuestro bono por
lo tanto a la mitad estaremos en 12
meses aquí tendremos 18 meses y más o
menos aquí serán 6 meses
porque los hemos puesto bueno pues
porque tendremos pagos o cupones
semestrales si nuestro bono el día de
hoy tiene un precio de 1000 dólares
calculemos entonces que el 10% de estos
mil dólares son 100 dólares estamos de
acuerdo vamos a poner que entonces estos
100 dólares son el 10% que nos pagará
cada año y si tendremos los pagos
semestrales pues entonces nos dará 50
dólares cada seis meses es decir en seis
meses tendremos 50 dólares en 12 meses
tendremos 50 dólares con esto suman los
100 que son el 10% anual en 18 meses
tenemos 50 dólares y en 24 meses
tendremos 50 dólares pero también al
final de los 24 meses nos pagarán el
valor nominal de nuestro bono
recibiremos mil dólares más los 50
correspondientes al semestre ahora
analicemos hoy si la compañía de acuerdo
al riesgo y a la tasa de intereses emite
bonos pagaré mil dólares por este bono
esto es una buena tasa de interés
entonces el nivel de riesgo me da
perfecto lo compro
ahora qué pasaría si al día siguiente
bueno no al día siguiente las tasas no
se mueven así pero por efectos de este
ejercicio vamos a pensar que al día
siguiente sube la tasa de interés es que
está en el mercado y ahora la gente está
esperando una tasa del 15% anual vamos a
escribirlo con otro color
esta vez la tasa sube
la tasa de interés sube
y la gente tiene una expectativa del 15%
sobre sus bonos
qué sucedería respecto al precio si
ustedes llegan y ustedes han comprado
este bono y de repente sube la tasa de
interés
llegan conmigo y me dicen oye sabes
necesito liquidez necesito efectivo y no
me puedo esperar los dos años que me
tomaría recuperar mis mil dólares más el
dinero en medio y me dicen oye estaría
dispuesta a comprarme este bono bueno yo
lo que pensaría es decir si te lo
comprará tendría que ser a un precio
menor y aquí está el por qué yo te
pagarían menos de mil dólares dado que
el día de hoy si yo comprara un bono en
el mercado similar a una compañía con
mil dólares a dos años pero que ahora
esta tasa de interés tiene el 15 por
ciento pues yo recibiría más de lo que
tú me estás ofreciendo es decir yo
recibiría el 15 por ciento de estos mil
dólares
anualmente cuando con el tuyo
simplemente recibiría el 10 por lo tanto
si yo pagara los mismos mil dólares
afuera recibiría más dinero que contigo
por lo tanto no me resultaría tan
atractivo a ti te ofrecería menos de mil
dólares en un momento más vamos a hacer
las matemáticas solo quiero que tengan
como la intuición de lo que significa
esto a mayor tasa de interés yo en el
mercado pudiera recibir un bono que me
dé mayor beneficio comparado con el que
tú me estás ofreciendo con una tasa
menor por lo tanto no me será tan
atractivo y solo estaré dispuesto a
pagarte menos de mil dólares
por este bono que tú me estuvieras
ofreciendo por lo tanto
el precio disminuida
y podemos decir que se estará vendiendo
este bono bajo la par o también lo
podemos llamar un bono descontado vamos
ahora a analizar el caso contrario
cambiemos de color
qué sucedería si la tasa de interés
entonces ahora bajará vamos a escribir
casa
de interés
baja
digamos que ahora en el mercado sólo
estará al 5% este 5 me quedó muy feo
vamos a escribirlo
5 %
entonces tú llegas y me dice sabes tengo
un bono necesito el dinero requiero la
liquidez cuánto estarías dispuesto a
pagar por este bono
que yo compré y que tiene una tasa de
interés del 10 por ciento yo te diría de
uva o sabes hoy si comprara un bono
similar por mil dólares sólo recibiría
el 5 por ciento de interés es decir
recibirían menos que el que tú me estás
ofreciendo por lo tanto estaría
dispuesto a pagar t
una mayor cantidad estamos diciendo que
como esta tasa de interés hoy en el
mercado desde el 5 por ciento pues
recibirían menos de lo que tú ya tienes
aquí que es el 10% por lo tanto sería
tal vez un buen negocio para mí
comprarte este bono y estaría dispuesta
a pagar un precio mayor entonces
hablaríamos de pagar más de 1000 dólares
y con esto podemos llamarlo un bono
sobre par o un bono con prima podemos
llamarlo
bueno
sobre par
y también pongamos el nombre de arriba
que habíamos olvidado bueno
descontado
es decir este bono se está pagando bajo
par- que es el valor nominal mil dólares
y este otro bono está sobre par es decir
más de mil dólares que es el valor
nominal ahora vamos a hacer las
matemáticas para saber el precio real
que alguien que digamos que está
razonando su elección estaría dispuesto
a pagar por un bono ok con base en lo
que sucede en las tasas de interés que
justo acabamos de describir les parece
bien vamos a hacer espacio para poder
hacer esto bueno y como les decía vamos
a hacer la parte matemática de este bono
cupón cero y para esto les mostraré un
bono cupón cero que es este moro cupón
cero no paga intereses durante su vida
sino hasta el final recupera él
el valor del bono y las matemáticas son
muy sencillas con estos vamos a escribir
nuestro bono cupón cero por mil dólares
vamos a utilizar información similar
entonces tenemos nuestro bono cupón cero
vamos a llamarlo también de una compañía
o del gobierno y sera
por mil dólares
este bono cupón cero también tendrá un
tiempo de madurez de dos años
y vamos a poner lo que es de la compañía
les parece bien este bono es un bono que
acuerda pagar el valor nominal los mil
dólares que les acabo de decir y estará
pagando a dos años este valor nominal no
hay pagos parciales como lo vimos en el
bono anterior en nuestro diagrama de
pagos se vería así recuerdan que
nosotros teníamos nuestra línea de
tiempo en este caso tenemos el día de
hoy que es el día en el que se emite el
bono
y estaremos a dos años o veinticuatro
meses al futuro
en el caso anterior teníamos pagos cada
seis meses
este es un bono cupón cero por lo tanto
recuperaremos el dinero hasta finalizar
el periodo de maduración aquí tendremos
un año
y el segundo año o 24 meses aquí al
final
este bono cupón va a tener un 10%
día 1 tendrá el valor de 10% nuestro
bono cupón cero entonces si calculamos
esto tendremos un precio que se
multiplicará por 1.1 cada año este será
el interés que me dará durante un año
más el bono original y para el segundo
año lo volveremos a multiplicar
por el bono original
y su respectivo 10% esto es lo que
deberíamos de recibir a dos años donde p
es el precio que nosotros estamos
dispuestos a pagar otra manera de
pensarlo es que el precio que alguien
estaría dispuesto a pagar si esperáramos
el 10% como retorno es el valor presente
no es el valor el día de hoy de mil
dólares en dos años descontado al 10%
vamos a reescribir esto donde el precio
que estamos dispuestos a pagar por el 10
por ciento por el 10% será igual vamos a
quitar esta pena será igual a mil
dólares
este será el valor presente de los mil
a dos años descontado al 10%
entonces la operación matemáticas
quedaría como p
por 1.10 al cuadrado lo tenemos aquí un
par de veces será igual a mil dólares
y el precio que estaremos dispuestos a
pagar el día de hoy pues el valor
presente será igual a los mil dólares de
un futuro
entre unos puntos 10 al cuadrado
cuál será este valor presente de los mil
dólares que estamos considerando a dos
años descontados al 10% que es 1.10 o
uno más el 10% vamos a sacar la
calculadora y hagamos esa división mil
entre
1.10 al cuadrado
lo que nos dará 826 punto 44 dólares
vamos a redondear lo a 826 dólares el
precio que hoy
el precio que hoy estaríamos dispuestos
a pagar sería 826 dólares
considerando que en dos años nos darán
mil dólares a una tasa del 10% esto
sería como un precio razonable qué pasa
si la tasa sube al día siguiente bueno
como les había dicho realmente no sube
pero para términos matemáticos vamos a
pensar qué
siempre será un tiempo de maduración de
dos años ok pensemos que será un día
menos si el día de mañana subieran pero
no cambiarán drásticamente las
cuestiones matemáticas vamos entonces a
pensar que es el siguiente segundo
cuando las tasas de interés han
incrementado vamos a escribirlo con otro
color las tasas de interés
han subido en el mercado y ahora la
gente está esperando una tasa del 15%
si nosotros hiciéramos otra vez la parte
matemática ahora la gente espera más
dado que la tasa de interés ha subido la
expectativa es tener el 15 por ciento de
retorno ya no el 10% que estábamos
manejando entonces cuál sería el precio
que estaríamos dispuestos a pagar la
lógica nos indica que si la tasa ha
subido en el mercado yo estaría
dispuesto a pagar menos por este bono
que ya existe estamos de acuerdo vamos a
usar la misma fórmula que será p
es igual a 1000 dólares originalmente
pero ahora la tasa no es del 10 por
ciento desde el 15 tendremos ahora un
número mayor en el denominador
ok vamos a tener el valor presente de
este bono pero ahora compuesto a dos
años la lógica me dice que si este
número va a ser más grande ahora en el
denominador pues tendremos un precio
menor estamos de acuerdo vamos a sacar
la calculadora una vez más y ahora
tendremos
mil dólares que serán divididos
entre nuestro precio más la tasa de
interés que será 1.15 al cuadrado porque
está a 2 años y entonces tendremos un
precio de 756 dólares
756 dólares lo ven cuando esta tasa
incremento en el mercado pues ahora
nosotros estaremos dispuestos a pagar
menos dado que si yo comprara un bono en
el mercado pues aquí tendría un mayor
retorno que en este caso por lo tanto
sería más atractivo comprar fuera que
comprar este si yo llegara a comprar
este pues ofrecería menos
que los 826 dólares que hemos visto
hasta el momento esto es lo que alguien
pagaría en caso de tener 15% como
retorno y un bono por mil dólares a dos
años digamos a alguien que esté
resonando a su compra ya para terminar
el ejemplo qué pasaría si la tasa ahora
baja vamos a ponerlo con otro color la
tasa de interés ahora
estará bajando
digamos que en el mercado la expectativa
será de 5% usaremos exactamente la misma
fórmula
donde el valor presente
de este bono o el precio que yo estaría
dispuesto a pagar sería igual a los mil
dólares para recibir en dos años en tren
11.05 esta vez porque la tasa ha
disminuido
compuesto a dos años sacaremos la
calculadora y haremos esta división
tendremos ahora mil dólares entre
11.05 al cuadrado
y nos dará 900 7 dólares y tiene todo el
sentido
907 dólares lo ven ahora estamos
dispuestos a pagar
más por el bono que tú nos estás
ofreciendo dado que en el mercado solo
tengo el 5% y tú me estás ofreciendo el
10% tendré un mayor beneficio por lo
tanto estaré dispuesta a pagar más por
tu bono que por el que se encuentra en
el mercado
ven matemáticamente cuando las tasas de
intereses suben el precio que
originalmente estaba en 826 dólares se
fue a 756 dólares ha disminuido el
precio que estaríamos dispuestos a pagar
y cuando la tasa de interés disminuyó
pues se fue de 826 dólares a 907 dólares
en este caso el precio incremento espero
que este vídeo haya sido claro y les sea
útil